ein blutbad mit zehn toten angerichtet
in kanada die nationen schockstarre und
ein täter ist noch immer auf der flucht
der zweite der beiden messer angreifer
wurde währenddessen tot aufgefunden
vier tote und mindestens 15 verletzte
das ist die grausame bilanz des
verheerenden anschlags in kanada vom
wochen in jetzt wurde einer der
mutmaßlichen täter tot aufgefunden und
das mit sichtbaren verletzungen so eine
polizeisprecherin
konstantin pm
um 13 uhr 17 wurde von den ermittlern
bestätigt der tot aufgefundene mann ist
damien center sind seine leiche wurde
neben einem haus aufgefunden es wird
angenommen dass seine verletzungen nicht
selbst zugeführt werden die genaue
todesursache wird in zusammenarbeit mit
dem gerichtsmediziner in saskatchewan
ermittelt
sein bruder miles der mutmaßliche zweite
angreifer sei weiterhin auf der flucht
die beiden hatten am sonntag in mehreren
gegenden des indianer reservats james
mit screen nation und dem dorf werden
ein blutbad angerichtet
polizei fahndete sofort nach den brüdern
das motiv der täter immer noch unklar
laut ermittlern haben die täter ihre
opfer wird zufällig ausgewählt
[Musik]